[Music]
in where the boys at news right here
submitted by living spaces jingle
metastasis Wow it works so well
mayor heart yeah they do keys keys keys
keys
that's a Beach Boys song though yeah
that was the best one okay Amir is
offering a reward to the first couple to
have a boy in a village where only girls
are born Wow what is in the water wait
what what huh you trying to make that
boy 2 up you just measure your ovulation
cycle and then and then have sex during
the time where it's the farthest away
from the ovulation because then the
girls will survive long enough the girl
sperm survived long enough to get there
yet to have a girl yeah yeah yeah that's
what they apparently you're doing yeah
have too many girls
that's offense I'm saying you can you
can plan it that you saying that boy
sperm like you know like guys are in
charge of the making a girl or a boy the
chromosome yeah I've heard that
propaganda recently we donate the white
chromosome yeah yeah that's the one I
get them confused so then they're saying
like what Nikki's saying is that like
the boy sperm they're fast they're fast
and they die faster you're sprinters
yeah so there's a view if you have sex
closer to the ovulation day you'd
probably have a boy because they'll get
there faster so guys are even faster as
sperms that's like it isn't real life
I'm just talking about how we're
superior at sports no you're not you die
faster you Mauro we get there faster in
sperm [ __ ] Oh even as sperms were
faster than you [ __ ]
Prince Steve sometimes it's a marathon
that's why you can't have guys versus
girls cuz we'll just pull you guys out
of the water even as [ __ ] [ __ ] do me
do it and I'll [ __ ] I'll slaughter I
don't think you will
I'll slaughter I'm a boy Geo
I slaughter knew what we were just going
on a light jog neighborhood he's like I
gotta stop that's a long distance
I used to jog to the block and then jog
back to him and so on but I'm faster
than you in a short distance it supports
become very you're not faster though I
had to slow my pace 10 and then do the
new in a short sprint and see I'll push
it through the [ __ ] door if I run
next door we got to do it outside
yeah we'll do it alright let's do it
take my shoes off because I got wedges
on now girl you'll beat him with those
that's true let's take one of the
cameras off the tripod let's go out in
the law and let's settle this [ __ ]
3-step racer record of my phone I'm
talking down how many steps
oh no it's cuz it's cuz you you like you
but you like your sprint has to only be
like from here to that bookshelf
distance yeah scuse me that's how they
that's something rate college players
and tell if they're gonna be in the NFL
okay honey you got me I'll do before
I'll do a four on four or five on you
right now I'm sorry you're so fast okay
you so you see that I would beat you in
a sprint right yes
drop it I wanna hear the article I want
to see the race they're always faster
even come faster hell yeah guys yeah
okay so a Polish mayor is offering
locals a reward if they're the first
family to have a baby boy because the
last baby boy to be born in this village
was 12 years ago
in C they want boys so they've been have
they've been producing nothing but girls
yeah just like a polish Amazon town
and women's yeah so it's mainly women
majority a woman so they're saying that
the population here is less than 300 and
most of them are females
Wow Wow Wow yep all the guys are super
peaceful they have cry circles and
smells really good
more tea when they go to that one planet
where it's all females but they don't
feel like they have real friendships
there's a lot of bitterness behind this
well that's why you go to a hut for PMS
week there you go
what's the boy's bathroom smells better
Oh true with only two guys there's a
bunch of cobwebs
it's beautiful TIFF and it's we just
said it smells good if I organized
you don't live that pretty yeah like
sparkles everywhere oh yes oh nice okay
they probably have awesome brunches yeah
yep I don't have heavy ceilings though
because I can't even build that [ __ ]
yeah we don't need it though we can we
can do it yeah
Mia tip could do it yeah but they don't
have Mexicans there I be it like put it
over there okay no okay with the tyrant
robot me not like that would not want to
go in the city full of guys [ __ ] no all
guys City [ __ ] but we're saying this is
like a heaven on earth yeah you're just
disgusted you guys is like violent in'
yeah hey city of god - so this one dad
who has two girls so that they need to
look into it further and they need to
review birth certificates and really
find out what's the correlation here why
is this village mainly women and the
part does one quote that kind of like
earth me a little bit he was like yeah
women in this village just don't birth
males I'm like you stupid [ __ ]
it's literally true the women are not
burdening me
it's not it's kind of like a [ __ ]
stance ready men it's like or not you're
not giving us a hammer so weird like
yeah we're trying to hammer this with a
screwdriver of course is not gonna be
correct okay but to be to nail this he's
supposed to say man the man's calm is
not producing the correct genome the
[ __ ] allow males are producing the
right sperm right that we and women are
modeling for it just takes so many words
to get there instead just don't say it
brevity is the soul away getting there
quicker is smarter than [ __ ] working
your ass off to get there and cover it
correct it's quicker and therefore is
more not incorrect that's literally true
what if he said the guys just don't
birth guys it doesn't work that sounds
confusing just because guys don't birth
anything because you ask more questions
don't mail chromosomes are getting
delivered to the women yeah
thanks Nikki well yeah real easy for
everyone village the guys are producing
too much feel oh he's [ __ ] pointing
out the obvious it's like you know [ __ ]
we see it'll be obvious I wonder what
they do for food the girls meeting and
it went by so fast because it's so
efficient for like oh yeah that sounds
good okay you do that you do that granny
was very organized like a guy so that's
how we get our food that's did a good
impression of a guys meaning how many
guys are in this village though like
what's the percentage it's just majority
women because if they say majority I
mean majority could be like 55% it is
majority but I think the part that's
really shocking here is that the last
time there was a boy that was born was
music that's pretty sick that's crazy
they're saying here is that so all these
girls are gonna have any guy to mate
with exactly Oh see it guys think like
oh my god so much [ __ ] if I go to this
village yeah but it is not what they
picture it is not Amsterdam with a
[ __ ] red-light district and a bunch
of ladies in like lingerie and [ __ ] you
talk about village ladies I see
I feel like I feel like it's beat farmer
ladies oh yeah
bunch of babushkas and [ __ ] you don't
know like yeah it's not sexualized I
think of Amish villages there's no
electricity there's no internet there's
no cell towers it's all Amish to him
yeah we'll do they have it or all the
TVs just like a wire clothing hanger
small little town it's not like they
probably just had sex in the city on
every channel like guys are like I'm
gonna go ahead and [ __ ] all these girls
it's like nah dude have you ever been to
a small town everybody talks and you
just probably can't [ __ ] more than one
girl yeah cuz I picture whenever a lady
needs to take a shower just to go to the
well first and get [ __ ] a pail of
water bring it back and performer you
should see them what's the legal sex age
then because like those women are gonna
get super old by the time this guy is
ready to have sex all right is that
tutorial made remember they're not an
island they can go out and find other
man oh they're not an island
yeah why do they need a guy so bad do
the other dudes come and pluck him away
so this one guy that he moved into this
village so he married a local girl and
he ended up having two girls oh come on
it's like uproot and then just [ __ ]
move somewhere else
the women are cursed their male sperm
yeah yeah it like changes their balls
that like yeah like zaps them once they
go into this circle I guess if you want
a daughter though then you go I'm gonna
go there
well I want a daughter so everyone goes
there to [ __ ] and so funny to think
about back in the day how like Kings
used to think that their wives weren't
giving them some so they'd haven't
killed in [ __ ] but then but then like
the scientist comes he's like actually
King I think it has to do with like your
and he's like off with your [ __ ] head
first twelve scientists that sit there
all day yeah [ __ ] yeah so then the only
then the science back then it's like yes
sir the science is that you're it's your
wife dude for sure I look it up yeah do
you think maybe there's some stuff like
something in the Bible or like with
religion because the way I'm trying this
correlation is with that with the show
where I'm drawing a blank
no the one with oh I had my detail show
it's all about how like America turns
into this crazy different world where
religious people take over and their
whole thing is that there's no more
procreation like there can't make babies
anymore and so they end up having these
handmaids to make these babies because
they've had kids in the past and they're
they always put it on The Handmaid's to
get pregnant but the guys are the ones
that are sterile but they're not blaming
it on the women so I'm like cuz there's
something in the Bible there that it's
like the women are at fault no I mean in
that show they do test the guys and to
see if he's he's okey sterile he's not
still - there's a section where there
like a guy well in the in that show
specifically like if you have you
watched all of it okay cuz is it there
isn't that one of the commanders they
find out that he's sterile no the doctor
ends up telling the girl like hey you
know most of these commanders are still
or anyway like the doctor was awful
guard to get her pregnant and then
that's why she ended up having to have
sex with it with the eyes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah cuz the main guys are here I
think just the old school thought maybe
that all the responsibilities on the
bellator because we ate an apple I guess
yeah cuz you eat the [ __ ] Apple and
you're made out of Arabs but you sure
aren't that thankful for it your ribs
aren't that great
pretty good if you think about it did a
lot with that room yeah
[Music]
[Music]